>>Neil Strauss: Yeah, I spent, like, ten years
writing for the New York Times and more, more
than that kind of writing for Rolling Stone.
If you're a writer you have always have your
dream of doing your, like, a journalist anthology
so you save, like, every article you've done
I put it into a folder called like 'anthology'.
I figured that, you know when the time came
and it was right for it, I would do my kind
of journalistic anthology. And what happened
was, so I started collecting these pieces
like I remember that were like my first big
break was going to Seattle in '94 and like
covering Kurt Cobain's suicide. It was an
intense thing for, like, a young guy, to be;
so I put that in there. Then my second thing,
the other stories I started putting in, even
before 'The Game'. And 'The Game' even though
they say it is more of a book on how to pick
up girls, for me it was really was to me a
book about male insecurity and my own insecurities
and fears. But, before 'The Game', I realized
that when I did this book, I spent six months
for the New York Times going like undercover
as a stand-up comic, trying to make it as
a stand-up comic. The reason I had them, made
them give me that assignment is I wanted to
get over, like, my nervousness, I wanted to
get over stage fright. I wanted to get over
social anxieties. Even like pre-'Game', that
was kind of like my first attempt to do that.
So anyway, I saved all these in a folder and
my last book after 'The Game' was such an
intense experience. It was called 'The Emergency';
it was kind of based on all the shit that
was going on and is still going with like
the economy and natural disasters. And everything
that we've still kind of seen happen in the
last kind of scary last eight or so years.
So and for that book I basically was; 'the
Game' was an intense kind of two, two year
experience. This was like kind of an overlap
of the Game and it was two years of learning
how to be self-sufficient. Learning how to
get off the grid. Learning how to basically
like recreate civilization, on my own. Uh,
with no one else. So it was such an intense
experience I thought maybe now was time to
take a little break. I told my publisher 'give
me two months and I will put together this
anthology.'
So, I opened up that little folder with all
those articles and I started reading them.
And I was like 'you know what? these kind
of suck.' Like, they weren't that good. Like
I thought all along they'd be like a whole
book then I realized, you know what? They
weren't as interesting as I kind of thought,
as I thought they were. And, and, I ordered
a bunch of anthologies by other writers and
I read them. All of them, like it was just
hard to read a book front to back that's a
collection of random articles written over
time. And also you just kind of get tired
of the writer's voice after a while. Like
gee, do you really want to read a profile
of like Tom Cruise written ten years ago in
a movie that we all forgot about?
So what I decided instead, was, that I would
get all the cassettes of all the interviews,
all the transcripts and all the recordings
of every interview I ever did. And I had them
all like re-transcribed. And I had them all
re-transcribed by a medical transcriber. And
I told her I want everything, like everything.
I want every cough. I want every pause; I
want every change in tonality. I want every,
uh, uh, every interruption, every background
noise. I want any, everything. So I got, you
know, twenty thousand plus pages of all these
cassettes. And by the way, these two months
turned into like two years [chuckles]. So
and it turned, I looked for these little moments
of authenticity.
And, and, that's kind of what we'll talk about
today. Which is my kind of goal as a writer,
when I go and do in an interview, especially
for like Rolling Stone and the New York Times,
it's not, I'm not gonna spend just an hour
in a room with a person; you're not going
to spend a day, a week, a month, or in one
case a year, embedded in someone's life. And
I'm looking for the moment where the mask
falls and I get to see who that person really
is. And that may not, may not, may not be
like a traditional sort of interview moment.
For example, when I was interviewing to Mötley
Crüe, the moment where the mask fell, was
like the moment I met them and they were getting
arrested. And like, as they were walking,
led away, and in handcuffs, it was just that
Nikki Sixx and Tommy Lee were getting arrested,
the moment that showed me who they were, was
when Vince Neal was like kind of blow drying
his hair the whole time. I thought 'OK'. That's
a moment. And then even better, like two fans
kind of ran up to them with copies of 'Shout
at the Devil' trying to get them to autograph
them as they were walking out. That's how
used to it the fans are to seeing these guys
get arrested.
Others were like so fun.
So I collected all those moments and went
through this whole long process to kind of
find the moments in the book. And the good
news is that as I was pulling up in my car
that I just found out from my editor from
Harper Collins that it made the New York Times
best seller list so I am really excited. Yeah.
[applause]
Which again is so awesome for an anthology.
So what I thought I'd do is I'd just read
a short thing and then I'd go over sort of
some lessons that we can apply to our lives.
[pause]. And uh, these are the things so even
though I on the surface it seems like the
book's about celebrities, to me it's just
about people. Like I feel I could stand on
any street corner and interview people for
a couple months and come up with something
as interesting as this. So um, tell you what,
we can read one of two things that I can read
to you this, when I spoke last time, I did
this. I am trying to decide which one. I'll
kind of read, I'll do, I will either read
A: 'Things overheard in my dangerous neighborhood
in New York' that I kind of wrote down. I'll
read that. I'll read that. Ok, I'll read that.
I haven't read this, I didn't read these last
time.
So these are in the books that I find it interesting,
I just take notes on life. I write nonfiction
because it's more interesting than anything
I can make up.
So I used to live in the East Village in New
York, before it was kind of cool and funky,
when it was just like dangerous [chuckles].
I remember like one time walking home, like,
three guys, just started kicking the shit
out of me and then they left. What was scary
wasn't just that they beat me up was that
they did not take my money. [laughter] Like
the whole event was just random violence.
If they took my money, I would have felt better
about it. It would be a goal-oriented behavior.
Instead it was just violence for the fuck
of it.
Um, so and then when I heard like a couple
people getting like held up by gunpoint outside
my window, I figured you know what, time to
move out. But before I moved I collected these
sayings. For those of you guys who haven't
been to New York or been to the East Village,
of course, I as soon as I moved out like six
months later, there's like velvet ropes and
nice restaurants and clubs there. But how
it works is that obviously New York is on
the grid system and there are numbers and
the streets are numbered and the avenues are
numbers. But as you go further east, they
turn into letters. The higher the letter in
this case, the worse the neighborhood; the
worst the block.
So this was overheard on Avenue B, two men
talking. "Just because I killed someone, doesn't
mean I'm expert."
[laughter]
On the same block, a man talking to a woman,
"I'm not a jealous guy, I'm just violent."
[audience chuckles]
Like he sounds like a keeper there.
On East Seventh Street, a guy saying "I'm
going to break your face, sucker" to a lamppost,
or maybe it was me. I don't know.
[chuckles]
Overheard this at a rave, "And the last thing
he did was drink a glass of orange juice.
Now he's in a mental institution and he thinks
he's an orange."
[chuckles].
Imagine if the last thing you did was take
a shit. That would have sucked! [chuckles]
On Avenue A, two well dressed white men talking
"I'm not a racist or anything. But have you
ever beaten up an African American?" And like
that is going to make it OK if he uses the
right PC term?
And then there's this bar, Seven B, two women
talking "He's a total fox so I love him. He
completely has no personality and he doesn't
speak a word of English."
So I took to running around the East Village
in a fox outfit, didn't work. [laughs]
And this was over on Avenue D some ways, two
guys talking "I don't take a life, I bury
a soul." I don't know what that means but
it's scary as fuck. [chuckles]
And then when I thought, since you guys were
here, and I actually have to do like a book
reading tonight. When I was in New York, I
started collecting a list of things I never
heard people say ever. What I thought is that
when I went to my reading tonight, do any
of you have like a regular pen. I would write
a list of things that I've never heard in
San Francisco. So this would be a collaborative
effort so I could do this during my reading
tonight.
I'll give you a couple examples to get your
mind working. So these are a few things, a
couple that apply to San Francisco so these
are things I've never heard in New York.
'No, go ahead. Take the parking space; you
were here first.' [audience laughs]
That one would be heard in San Francisco.
Um, 'thank God the police are here.'
Never heard that.
'Oh yeah, would you like at that? My bike
is still here.' [laughter]
'Um, are you Neil Strauss, the famous writer?'
Never heard that. [laughter]
So, there are a couple of others that I could
add for San Francisco that would be like specific?
[pause]
Things you would never heard in San Francisco.
>>Male #1 member: [inaudible]
>>Neil Strauss: Yeah, Yeah, Nice sun, I love
your sun tan. All right we'll work on that
one.
[laughter]
We'll work on that one, I love your suntan.
>>Male #2: It's much too early for wine.
>>Neil: That's good.
>>Male #3: Yes, I am a mister.
>>Neil: [laughing] Ha, ha, ha, yeah,
[audience laughs]
>>Neil: That's good.
[Pause]
>>Neil: Uh, I've been searching all day and
I can't find a Chinese restaurant. No, is
that yes or no? I don't know. Maybe
>>Female #1: [inaudible]
>>Neil: What's that?
>>Female#1: Maybe Thai food.
>>Neil: I can't find a Thai restaurant.
[pause]
>>Neil: OK, we'll go with those. If you think
of others, just yell them out as I'm speaking
later.
>>Female #1: Go to brunch.
>>Neil: What's that?
>>Female #1: I can't find a good brunch place.
>>Neil: I can't find anywhere for brunch.
[audience yells]
>>Neil: What the hell, yeah, what the hell
is Burning Man? That's a good one.
I love the night life here. No. [laughter]
>>Female #2: So many taxis.
>>Neil: Yeah,
[pause]
>>Neil: [laughing] Ha, ha, ha, that's good.
OK, awesome.
That was quick. Good job, guys.
All right, so here's the, so I'll give you
a choice of what we do next. We'll do one
of two things and then we'll do some questions
and answers, especially since I know we started
late. So choice one is once I went through
all these interviews for the book and put
them all together, and with the benefit of
twenty-twenty hindsight, you start to see
like themes that are immersed through them.
Like themes of lessons that you can kind of
learn for your own life. And I thought it
was like really interesting and there a lot
of surprises. Some were more intuitive, some
were counterintuitive. Some were like interesting
themes that I learned that to me I think about
all the time in terms of my behavior. Like
there's lessons in the book that I directly
apply to my behavior or try to apply. In fact
one I should be applying right now. [chuckles]
Then there's another one, That's choice one.
Choice is two is, uh, there's education and
then there's humor which is obviously I did
that book 'The Game' which means that for
the rest of my life I will be getting the
most insane emails. Probably most, the most
anyone than ever gets. So I collected like
the funniest emails. I'll give you small example.
I didn't write down; I just got it today.
It was a guy writing saying um, he was saying
"I've got a question: I'm twenty-seven years
old, I'm a virgin, um, you know, a few girls
said if I would pay for their, uh, breast
implants, they would let me touch them. Do
you think I should do that?"
[audience laughs]
So, they're along, they're along, they're
along those lines.
So, humorous emails, educational life lessons?
What do we feel like?
[audience shouts]
Emails? What's that?
Life lessons.
[laughs]
Who said emails?
Alright,we'll do life lessons and we'll end
with two emails
So, you're pretty good with your life is that
what you're trying to say? [audience laughs]
But I felt like it would have given me a good
like temperature of the company and people
as well. If everyone's like emails, then we
work too hard, we think too much, just entertain
us. If everyone wants life lessons, it really
means like you know you want to get out of
here at some point in our lives and do something
else. [laughs]
So life lessons.
You don't have to comment on that. If you
laughed, you've all been recorded.
So first one and this it was the first was
really Let Go of the Past.
What was amazing when I did these interviews
and I interviewed people like Chuck Berry
who invented Rock and Roll basically, and
Bo Diddly who and Jerry Lewis who left like
such a huge legacy on music. And it here's
these guys, who like are almost afraid to
go outside, who think everybody hates them
because of some scandal that happened like
thirty years ago. The lesson from that is
that literally, we've all have shitty things
happen to us in the past. We all have, you
know, whatever whether it's relationship or
a parenting thing or a scandal or a, you know,
some humiliation something that didn't work
out. You deal with it the best you can at
the moment. Then you have to let go and move
on. And the crazy thing is that all the shitty
things, in the moment, like enrich you later.
Not just as a person, but actually to other
people. And you'll see in the book, like I
was trying to explain to Chuck Berry, that
yeah, maybe when you transported a minor across
state lines for immoral purposes, that was
bad at the time and you went to jail. That's
true. And at the time, it really did hurt
and destroy your career. The crazy ironic
thing is that although that may that is still
wrong, it actually just made you more interesting
to people now. No one's judging you for it
anymore; it's just a story now. And I think
if like that's true for that, a lot of what
we've been through, it becomes that too.
So letting go of the past, and focusing on
what, you know, focusing on being great at
what you enjoy and be glad of your accomplishments
is important.
Next one is, and this is, definitely true
that it's a west coast thing thing. That fame
and wealth won't make you feel any better
about yourself. Because I see so many people,
and especially in LA, like trying to feel,
like feeling like, if they get famous or get
a lot of money, that's going to fix all their
problems of insignificance; of insecurity;
of worthlessness and disconnection. And of
course, the real lesson is that rather than
fixing one's problems like the more fame and
wealth like magnify them. And those little
things that aren't a big problem in your life
become huge and that's where we get to enjoy
on the front page of the tabloids and watching
Charlie Sheen, and then everything else.
And the corollary to that then is that fix
your problems now because the older you get,
the worse they'll become. And I have this
fear of that because I was talking to a friend
of mine, a producer; if you guys here read
'Rules of the Game', not sure if guys read
it but conversation with this producer in
the front and to the back like kind of anonymous
producer who is kind of my, a good mentor.
And I told him I had started this list on
my computer, and the list is: Notes to myself
as an old man. Things I need to watch out
when I get older. Because when you get older,
that thing that keeps you in check is going
to start to turn off and you're just going
to, all those sides to yourself that you try
to repress are just going to come out. And
the notes are things like "don't be paranoid;
everyone's not out to get you; they have better
things to do than worry about an old man."And
so, things like that. And he said, 'you know
what? Instead of writing them down now to
read later, why don't you fix those problems
now then you don't have to worry about them
at all when you are older'. I thought that
was kind of wise advice.
Next thing, this probably applies here, is
that, the people I've interviewed who have
gotten really successful by working really,
really, really hard, are pretty unhappy people.
Um, and that people who you know, party all
the time with tons of girls and drugs and
all that kind of stuff are not only end up
unhappy but usually end up in jail or dead
or at least in rehab. And the people that
I've interviewed who are sort of like the
happiest, the ones whose lifestyle you might
say "ok, you've got a good lifestyle" are
the ones who found like balance at some point.
So I really believe that the secret to happiness
is balance: Um, and, and devoting some amount
of your life to work; some amount to you know,
family, love, relationship; some amount to
doing something physical and healthy everyday;
some amount to contemplative time to yourself.
Kind of keep that in balance then you are
OK. If you are going to places in your work,
and you are doing awesome. Like you are not
doing well if you are out of balance.
I feel like, I just did a Howard Stern cover
story for Rolling Stone. What was interesting
was that, the last question I asked him was,
you know, you're on radio two radio stations,
twenty-four hours a day, you got your own
TV stations, you're on TV twenty-four hours
a day and no one's bored. You've got a great
wife and happy relationship. You make more
money than even like the late night talk show
hosts. Why are you still unhappy? You know,
and that was the answer that there's that
anger and he never worked on it and uh you
know, he's only just now trying to discover
and trying to find balance. So I felt like
it's a hard thing. It's easy to know; it's
hard to do in our lives. Especially at our
ages.
And one other corollary that I meant to add
is to the fixing your issues now thing. I
do think that one of the goals, one of the
goals in life is that when you're young, you're
handed from like, say from age 1 to 12 or
something, you're handed a certain amount
of issues by your parents. You know, even
if you have good parents that love you, you
still get a certain amount of issues as well
as your kind of social groups. You get a certain
amount of baggage. And I think one of your
goals in life is to try and you know, recover
from that baggage. To vest yourself of it.
So you can kind of become that clean, great
person you were when you were born and return
to that. Not in a New Age way, but deal with
that baggage and let go of it and be happy
again. That's one of the goals of evolving
through life outside of the family and love
and the thing and as someone once told me,
that when someone's on their death bed, they
never think about "Shit, I didn't finish that
book" or "I didn't finish that project". Or
um, you know "I didn't finish the album I
was making or anything". They always think
about family and love.
And you'll see at the end of the book, it's
kind of thematic things if you guys read it.
The last sections about, about death. People
who are close to dying or thinking death.
And I was really struck and I don't, and I
never, and I still don't fully understand
it that I was really struck but it. There's
a bluegrass musician named John Hartford.
And he wrote a song called 'Gentle on my Mind'
which was a big hit for Glen Campbell and
was one of the most recorded songs. What was
interesting about interviewing him, was he
had a I think he had leukemia and he knew
he had like a year or two left to live and
that was it. And he had chosen in that time,
to get better at playing the fiddle. That
was all he was going to do was sit at home,
and he would play the fiddle. Other pickers
would come over, he'd record it and play it
back and he'd try to get better at the fiddle.
He's just really happy with that choice. It
was an amazing, beautiful thing that I still
can't understand in my head because of course,
no matter how good you get, you know, at one
point, you're gonna, obviously, be gone, and
none of that's gonna matter. But I just thought
he made his choice, he was happy with his
choice and I still have yet to really, fully
understand the significance of that choice
he made. I found it really fascinating.
Versus, Rick James [laughs] whose last words
to me when I interviewed him were I said "What
are your plans for the New Years?"He said
"I plan to leave that mother-fucking cocaine
alone." And of course he died a couple years
later of a heart attack with cocaine in his
system. There's a guy who never got to make
his choice and live it for what he was going
to do with life.
I'll give you a couple of the really quick
ones
I wrote a piece for the Wall Street Journal
about one of the more surprising things that
I found in this book. Which was that musicians
who believe in God, and that believe that
God like had a plan for them to be famous,
it was God's plan for them to be famous, became
more famous and got to stay there longer.
It doesn't mean then, I don't believe this
is a religious belief obviously this is delusional
narcissism that you know are chosen out of
everybody by God to be famous. That he even
fucking cares of you have a Billboard number
one or whatever. You know, like, every Super
Bowl, the fucking team who wins, I don't really
watch much sports. But the team who wins and
the MVP every fucking Super Bowl is always
like "this was God's plan." Like God is just
sitting there, fucking watching the game [laughs].
Like that's going to matter the fate of the
world if that team wins. [audience laughs]
And I suppose in chaos theory, maybe it would,
but anyway.
The point being, that versus musicians that
I interviewed and I think the reason that
it works is this: If you're on a level and
one of the reasons I named the book 'Everyone
Loves You When You're Dead" is that as you're
getting, as you're improving yourself, if
you're sticking your head out, whether you
are rising at the company, whether you are
a guy who read 'The Game' and doing better
with women. Any time you're doing better,
everybody will start to shit talk you and
take you down because your success makes everybody
else feel worse about themselves.
That's why we love shit talk with celebrities;
we don't shit talk homeless people. You know
like we love shit talking celebrities because
they are up there and we want say "Hey, they're
no better than us. Hey, look at them; they're
fat; they're thin; they're falling apart.
Look at them, they suck". So to anyway, to
be there to withstand all the things being
thrown at you, if you're like "everybody hates
me but God's on my side, so fuck you all."
You know you can have that strength to go
through it versus people I interviewed like
Jack White who had a lot of insecurity and
doubt about where they were and hey, not everyone's
goal is to be famous and misused. So, you
know, I think it's better to be a great artist
personally. But to people who have a lot of
faith, doubt, and insecurity ended up not
staying there because it's hard. You don't
end up making choices that aren't good for
you because you're worried about whatever
one else will think.
So really quickly just a couple of the lessons.
One is derive your self-esteem from within,
not from others' opinions. And I think that
almost goes without saying the corollary of
that is that how I meet these people recorded
these seminal albums maybe Brian Wilson and
Pet Sounds. And them and the people are still
haunted by the bad reviews it got even though
these albums maybe changed the course of music.
Uh, [pause]
Next one: I'll do this one really quickly.
Never say never. because everybody I ever
interviewed who's ever said as they're up
and coming "I'm never going to move Las Angeles
and start dating a model. I'm not going to
be that cliché," has done it. To the letter.
And often the things that you say, that you
say, never about, I'm not going to do that,
because that's so cliché, are usually often
'cause you're envious of it. Or because, uh,
if you know the main idea of the Shadow? The
shadow is the side of yourself that you don't
like. The shadow is the side of yourself that
you want to get rid of; that you don't want
to show to other people that you wish wasn't
there, just the secret side that you try not
to show anyone. The reason you don't want
to be on a reality show is because that side's
going to come out. So whenever you meet somebody
and you have an instant dislike to them, you
just meet someone for just no reason you just
instantly dislike them, the reason you have
that emotion, is either envy or you're seeing
your shadow, you're seeing the side of yourself
that you don't like. That you don't want to
have that you want to cut out in that person
that's why else would you have that extreme
a reaction to them.
Um, the next one, I think is very important.
It's like saying yes to everything, within
reason. Saying yes to new things. I meet so
many people who have sabotaged their own careers
because they say "I'm not going to do that
because I'm not getting paid for it" or I'm
not going to do it, even though they want
to do it, it's something that they want to
do, you know, or they not getting enough respect,
I'm leaving this whole thing. Then the person
who takes their place like wins some award
or something. I've seen this happen so many
times and most of the people who got to where
they got to, did it by just you know saying
yes to new things, even if they didn't always
know what they were. Even if they weren't
getting properly compensated when they were
trying to get there and so many people kind
of told them to do things over ego battles.
And one person who I love is Joseph Campbell
the, the professor of mythology. And his two
great sayings, Do you guys know. Do you guys
know Joseph Campbell? So a few people. He's
great. Great guy he studied all mythologies
and religions of the world and summed them
up so we can look at our culture and see what
our myths are that allow us to keep on functioning.
He knows everything about life; he's genius.
But his two great quotes: one is "Follow your
bliss"; here's another great quote "The insecure
way is the secure way" and the meaning of
that it's really important to know especially
at the age we're at is that you know all your
life you're told to make the safe decision.
You know, go get a job, to do something that
pays a lot of money because then you're gonna
be secure. The thing about that is that if
you make those choices either for money or
for security, you know, if you say, if you
just work at that job for three, four, five,
six years, seven years and you're getting
that money. All of that money goes away and
you've got nothing. You're screwed. And there
goes seven years and you've got nothing. Versus,
you make the choices that comes from you passion.
The truth is that the money probably won't
come. For the like first six months or year
or maybe after two years you can feed and
clothe yourself. Or maybe you can have a roof
over your head. If you're really good at it
maybe over five years you can finally get
to where other people got in just a little
bit of time. And the fact is, and I know for
myself, when I wanted to write, my parents
literally cut me off financially. I had to
cover the rest of college myself. I was so
broke. I spend my money on culture because
I love movies and books and TVs and stuff.
And movies and books and music. So I could
like spend my last five bucks to see a movie
like a repertory cinema and eat like someone's
left over popcorn that they left on the seat
because I literally had no money. That literally
was the best decision I ever made for my life.
The point being this, if you follow your bliss,
you follow your passion, if you do the thing
that you really, really, care about, and yes,
half the people who are listening will say
like 'Well I don't know what my passion is."
But there's something that you like that you
enjoy doing so you find out if that's your
passion. But you follow that thing. And you
keep doing it. You can, the money can go.
Maybe you never get to that place where you
make enough money. But the truth is that you
always have your passion. You can lose the
money but your passion is still there. That's
fulfilled. And you can be happy with what
you've done. Living your life, people can't
take that away.
The truth is that the insecure way, is really
the secure way because that's the most secure
place to be.
Last lesson: is that everyone loves you when
you're dead which to me I always think about
and I think it's true, it feels like a flip
title that "Everyone Loves You When You're
Dead" but it's really sort of a positive message.
In my mind because if you realize that most
of the negative stuff that people say is competition.
And the only reason they love you when you're
dead is because you are no longer competition
to them and then they can say nice things.
Not only are you no longer competition, you
have been appropriately punished for your
success. So if you remember that, it makes
it easier to walk through life know that whatever
shit that I'm dealing with is not really gonna
matter when I'm dead so maybe my optimistic
message to close this with is you know:
Live each day as if you have a fatal disease.
[chuckle]
Really I think it helps you make your priorities
set. If you are John Hartford and only have
a couple years left. What you're going to
do and decide to start doing it now.
Uh, so that's it. That's what I thought I
would talk about today. Let's uh we'll do
a couple of questions. If there are no questions,
I'll read a couple of those emails to kind
of close things off.
[clears throat]
[pause]
Yeah, um, yep.
>>Male #4: We have a microphone over here.
>>Neil: You know I was told I could come in
and talk about videos and things like that
but you guys know more about videos than I
know. You're probably sick of fucking videos.
>>Male #5: We never get sick of videos.
>>Neil: Um is that true?
[audience responds inaudibly]
[audience laughs]
>>Male #5: So I saw a, I saw a blog post from
you, um, couple days ago, copy writer, copy
editors-
>>Neil: Um, yeah, yeah, yeah.
>>Male#5: at the New York Times which was
really funny and uh, I was wondering if you'd
talk a little bit of the experience of you
as a writer dealing with these big publications
and having to go through these gatekeepers
who really control really word for word what
you're saying. And how you're presenting and
ideas and really change those ideas via versus
say as a like as a blogger or someone or someone
who is on Twitter where you have control of
your own words. And how's that changed for
you.
>>Neil: And I think and I think it's a good,
it's a good thought that one advantage in
this sort of blog you know make your own video
world is that advantages is that hey, there
is no, I mean there is some decency stuff,
but really you get your idea out there as
you want it unfiltered. So I think the good
side of say of just being a blogger is that
you get to communicate your ideas exactly
as you want them, the length you want, what
you want, put the paragraph breaks where you
want. The bad news of that is you don't get
the advantage of good mentors. I can guarantee
it, if I was in that world, I would not being
on my seventh fucking New York Times best
seller which is insane. Like which I can't
even fathom that I even have that in my life.
But I did have good editors who were not just
say friends who were giving advice but who
were saying "I can't publish this because
this is going to reflect badly on our publication
of our name if I don't fix this stuff and
tell you the rules by which I'm fixing this.
If I didn't have good editors who let's just
say changed stuff, censored stuff, organized
stuff, there's no way I could have written
like a book that would be readable from front
to back. There's no fucking way. So I feel
like having good mentors whose reputation
is at stake by what you're doing whether it's
your a film maker and someone's invested twenty
million dollars or something or you're a writer
and someone's going to put it in their magazine.
It's so essential to becoming a writer.
And I agree some of that is lost but especially
now as far as journalism goes, it's probably
like the worst place ever which is that you
just need to be first with a piece of news.
That's all; it doesn't even has to be news.
If you've got the fucking scoop that Justin
Bieber got a haircut a half an hour before
some other thing, and you get like one thousand
other sources pick that up and link in and
you get a lot of comments then you fucking
succeeded and your editors are happy. Versus
having a unique voice in writing. So I really
think we're in this kind of scary place. I
really know that this new book what's a lot
of the publicity and I've watched it happen,
mining out these little tidbits that some
celebrity said to these sites and watching
sort of take wings all over the Internet.
And it's been fascinating. It's been fascinating
to watch like kind of how it works and talking
to these journalist is a horrible place because
uh, this is giant popularity contest going
online and who knows art or culture knows
that the best stuff is not popular in the
moment because it's new. And if you are writer
and you are writing something from passion,
that is not going to get as many links as
that Justin Bieber got a haircut or Charlie
Sheen made up a new word thing where, you
know, where ah, we're gonna get all the incoming
links. And now they can track it now and they
say "No you're not getting enough clicks so
you're gone," even though you're the best
writer there. I think we're in sort of interesting
moments but I think it's going to shake out.
And what's going to ultimately happen when
everyone's writing about the same fucking
people that we're all sick of already. Wasn't
it amazing to watch, and I'm going on a long
answer, but wasn't it amazing to watch that
Charlie Sheen, like, sincerely was saying
warlock and winning and tiger blood and then
within a week, he's already being parodied
it in a video. Like that's how fast our culture
is moving now. That the sincere catch phrases
become parodied and jokes within a week. It
was amazing to watch the speed at which that
happened. So I think, obviously you guys are
part of it, we're really in an interesting
moment, transitional moment in our culture.
Yeah
>>Male #6: Hey Neil. Thanks for coming. I
was really curious about the thing you were
talking about at the very beginning about
the mask falling and building rapport with
some of these people that you've talked to.
Not just celebrities, but building rapport
with anybody like your friend or just anybody
you meet for the first time. And kind of also
the, I know you could riff on this for a long
time. I am also interested in this concept
of like balance with rapport. Like Wayne Elise
talks about-about using 'I statements' and
relating to the other person. And trying to
throw in bits of yourself as your trying to
talk with somebody else. Sort of like how
do you balance that and what are your thoughts
on the rapport building stuff.
>>Neil: Rapport building, I think rapport
building is really important. And this book
to me is really a lot about rapport building
which is building that connection with people.
Um, and do you mean it in terms whether maybe
it's an interview? Because I have certain
techniques I use in an interview versus maybe
a one-on-one situation or kind of both?
>>Male #6: Yeah, both, like yeah, like what
do you do to like get somebody to open up
and get to see the real them?
>>Neil: Yeah, cool. Yeah, I think, I think
the number one things that apply over all,
whether it's uh, in a, especially in interviews,
especially when in situations when meeting
people are being non judgmental is one of
the most important qualities you can have
as a person. People who are judgmental make
people closed off because they just say things
to get them. People say things just to get
them to approve of you. So also being curious
coming from a natural place of curiosity,
to me, whether it's with "The Game" stuff
and guys who are running around trying to
start these conversations with people. If
you didn't come from a natural place of curiosity
or really care about what you were asking
about or what the person had to say, it would
go flat. It was the same with the interviews
and same with connecting with someone. Like
I find and I find that curiosity is the most
important tool you can have. Like I'll be
at a dinner party, it's boring. I'll just
think "what's interesting about that person
there" and I'll share. Then I'll pick it out.
You know, for example if they are a Like they
are a radio host or something. I'll just think,
I'm curious why, you know, a lot of radio
hosts I find, do you ever just not want to
go in every morning and you have to do it?
And what if like you find out your wife cheated
on you, how do you go in-in the morning when
you when you wish or something heavy going
on and you got to be morning zoo man? And
also if you do that like you know guys who
are morning zoo men, I'm just kind of riffing
on this but you know, this is where I'll start
going. Is that I won't ask anything with an
agenda, you know. If you as soon as you want
to get something from someone, they are just
kind of like going to back off. Even if I
have an agenda, I'll always let them, them
raise it first. So anyway, I think we get
the point about curiosity, a natural curiosity
is the best way to connect with someone and
start that conversation. As well as being
nonjudgmental so they're open explaining it.
Combine that with deep listening. When you're
really listening for what they're saying,
and if they falter you know if they falter,
you know what's going on. And I love listening
and listening for cues. Like if you're in
a restaurant and you say and she says the
specials, and you say "How's the special?"And
she goes, 'uh', then you already know it sucks.
If she pauses before she tells you it's good,
you already know it sucks. [laughs]
So deep listening is important so like when
someone's about to pause, you're like 'what's
the truth behind that?' So deep listening
is the other thing and soon they forget who
you are and what your status is and what's
going on. They're sort of like, into this
conversation.
Um, and the other thing I was going to say
is when there's an elephant in the room and
the elephant room is if I'm interviewing someone
who has a big scandal or if you're talking
to someone and it's about your raise, or you
want a raise or you want something from them
because they are a higher status person, let
them bring up the elephant in the room. You
can lead them toward it. Once they bring it
up, then you're just asking the follow up
questions so I always allow, if somebody's
got a huge scandal, I'll bring it up from
that. Either I'll wait for them to bring it
up or if they're not bringing it up, um, I'll
try to ask questions from their point of view.
For example, if I'm interviewing somebody
and they just, uh, whatever the scandal is,
instead of just saying 'well, tell me about
the scandal' or what the public wants to know.
I don't care about what the public wants to
know. I care about what they are going through
and what are they thinking about this. If
you are trying to find out who they are dating,
for example, and you just say "Who are you
dating?" They'll just say "I can't tell you,
it's private."Uh, if but instead, you know,
because they're not thinking 'who am I dating'
because they know who they are dating, but
if you ask 'Are you sick of everyone asking
you who you're fucking dating?' they're like
"Yeah" and they'll start talking about it
and now that door is open. So just finding,
I guess the other the skill is besides those
would be like, uh, empathy, which is, which
I'm trying to think, like they're thinking.
I'm trying to ask questions from their point
of view not from what other people want to
know.
So there's a few things. If you want one good
sneaky thing, it's called trance words and
I'll just share that. It's a cool idea. This
is something that can apply to people. People
have like certain words that they load with
meaning, right? If somebody says, uh, I was
doing an interview with Tom Cruise, and he
was like, I think the word was extraordinary
and he was like "Man, it was just extraordinary"
and he like loads that with meaning. But I
talk like fucking talking about passion or
something; maybe passion is my trance word.
Certain words mean something to him. When
he said extraordinary, you can't say "Wouldn't
it be great?" you have to say "wouldn't it
be extraordinary" if we went and did that.
Wouldn't it be fucking extraordinary?
[laughter]Like yeah man, it'd be great. Which
I did. I did that with, I also knew the word
peace and extraordinary were important to
him. So I said "wouldn't be extraordinary
if you show me around Scientology Center?"
[laughs] And he did. [laughs]
So, you have to listen for those words; you
don't even have to know what the meaning is
but they invest extra emotional meaning. And
if you want to be a really N-L-P-E about it,
these things are fun, right, those little
things about the personality. If you really
want to be all N-L-P about it, like it'd be
fucking extraordinary. Watch what gesture
he does and you do the same gesture. Wouldn't'
it be fucking extraordinary to do that? [laughs]
I'll tell you one more really fun one since
we're talking; this is one of my favorite
ones. And I think his is an important rapport
thing. Is when we were doing "The Game", it
always comes down to "The Game" because it
is fucking interesting, but when we were doing
the game, we studied from everything to do
good. We read books on sexuality and marketing
and everything and some tips we got were from
like a book on selling houses. And here are
two tips that kind of go with rapport and
also for getting your agenda from a book on
selling house. Two great tips. One is that
you don't let somebody say no. So if you're
showing someone around a house and if you
are a guy going for a phone number and your
trying to get a job and you're on the fence,
For your showing them around the house and
you feel the No is coming, here's the bedroom,
do you feel like you guys are interested and
you feel like they're backing off. You don't
back them into no response. There's a principle
called commitment and consistency. As soon
as someone says no, they're gonna stick with
that no even if they didn't mean it at the
time. So you're like, you know what? You guys
haven't seen the kitchen. Check out the flooring
in the kitchen. You take them somewhere, you
move them around, take them somewhere else.
You then see how they feel about it and if
you're getting that no, you move them around
somewhere else. Show them another positive
feature and then you see how it's going. Once
they say that first No, they are stuck in
that no.
Second thing and this is fucking awesome.
Let's just say, you moved them into the kitchen
and they've seen all the great features and
now they want the house. And they say, "We
want the house." You say 'great' and I'll
prepare an offer. What do you guys want to
offer? They say whatever it is, probably in
this economy somewhere around two hundred
thousand dollars. They say "Great. Pleasure,
I'll call you tomorrow," and you leave. They
are going to get buyers' remorse. The mistake
is you are, you got along, you had this nice
friendship; they trusted you. And as soon
as you got the deal made, you were gone. So
the other thing I learned from selling houses,
once you close the deal, you know you stick
it around a little bit so they know it wasn't
just about closing the deal. So this is true
when you are out getting a girls phone number.
If you got the phone number, say "Awesome,
I'll call you tomorrow for plans," and then
you left. She's more likely to flake than
if you waited and said "Oh, the other thing
I forgot to tell you is," and you told another
funny story, and then you left then she'll
know it wasn't just about closing the deal,
or getting the phone number. It was about
making a connection with someone. So fun question.
Let's do a couple more because I know my answers
are going way too long. [chuckles]
>>Female #2: So I so, I recently read Patty
Smith's book "Just Kid"
>>Neil: "Just Kids," yeah.
>>Female #2: And something I thought was really
interesting was the benefit of the passage
of time. So when she was talking about like
hanging out with this woman who seemed like
kind of interesting, and that it turns out
later it was Janis Joplin and what that really
meant. But that her life at the time was these
series of moments, and like trying to deal
with shit, and later she could reflect back
on the other layers of meaning. I think that's
interesting for your example, for Pet Sounds
too.
>>Neil: Yeah.
>>Female #2: When you are talking about this
sort of anthology that you're building in
this folder and then later you're like, 'Oh
this is totally shit,' on the flip side like
have you had any of those moments where the
benefit of time where you were like 'Oh that
was actually like a turning point,'
>>Neil: Oh, for sure.
>>Female #2: I would just like to hear some
of these sorts of things.
>>Neil: For me like with the anthology was
looking through it and realizing that there
were specific questions that I was asking
artists at certain points of my life because
I was trying to figure out the answer for
myself. I saw these things almost like therapy
for me because I never went through therapy.
So I would be asked like, for example, I can
really see my own growth through the book
which I never expected. From my first interview
with Led Zeppelin, I was really young with
an opportunity to interview Robert Plant and
Jimmy Page. They were like titans of rock
and I was really young and nervous. And to
me there was important as great musicians
as they were as like guys who had sex a lot.
Because probably at that point, I had slept
with like two girls or something. And so I
remember I just kept asking them questions
like about at one point Jimmy Page says to
us "Do you have any questions for us that
don't involve sex?" [laughs]. So at that point
I was just a guy who and then and later my
questions start to turn like to work, you
know. If you had your choice between um, uh,
what's more important what's more important
in the world, the work you've done or your
children? What's more important? Cause I was
trying to figure out because I work so hard
but I was not taking care of family. And I
started asking questions about intimacy; about
work avoidance; being, you know, working so
hard being a way to avoiding intimacy. So
I can see through those questions that I read
it exactly where I was on like, my journey
in life and even my current like Howard Stern
issue of Rolling Stone issue and the things
that I'm dealing with, you know, now. I see
in those in those interviews to me even though
I'm just I'm an anonymous guy asking questions
like tells me so much about myself and where
and who I was. It was fascinating. It's a
cool question.
I gotta read "Just Kids." Everyone says it's
really good Patty Smith book. You guys should
have her come in and speak. [laughs] And she's
in the book and she says something great in
the book because she disappeared for a bunch
of years to be a mother and she got a lot
of shit for it. She said being a mother is
really the most noble thing you could do.
It's hard, often undignified work, but I'm
as proud of that as I am any of my albums
and stuff 'cause the public just thinks if
you're not feeding us new albums, you're obviously
wasting your life. And her answer to that
was just awesome.
Cool are there any more questions? I'll read
you guys two emails to go and then we'll let
you guys take off. Unless you have to get
back to work, you probably do. Fuck it. [laughs]
I'll just read it to you now, I'll read you
a sample and we'll end on this. These are
the kind of emails I get in my in box.
"Um, Dear Neil, How do I remove semen stains
from clothing?" [laughs]
[audience laughs loudly]
I don't know why they ask me.
"I ask because I had an unfortunate misfire
the other night [chuckles] and I don't want
to throw these clothes away. I tried the washing
machine with regular detergent but it's not
working. PS: I did a search. I couldn't find
anything helpful except using seltzer but
I don't know what seltzer is. Can you help?"
[audience laughs loudly]
It's so sad, right?
I actually answered that. I told him about
this stuff called Zout; it really works. [laughs]
"Dear Neil, What do you think about psychiatric
drugs and jerking off? I have taken Prozac,
Paxil, Celexa, Seroquel, Zyprexa, Geodon and
some other shit. Celexa couldn't make me come
although I finally did jack me off for like
twenty minutes straight. What a workout. No
wonder my right arms are massively bigger
than my left ones." [laughs]
Like how many arms does this guy have?
"Do you know, does you know the best medication
to take for jacking off?"
Um, let's see which one. I'll read you like
two more.
Um, OK, there was an idea in "The Game" called
'peacocking' which was dressing to stand out
from everybody else in some way. And this
guy writes,
"Dear Neil, I've got an idea for peacocking.
Dressing up like a monk. No one's ever tried
it before so it's definitely going to get
me laid." [laughs]
Maybe he's going for altar boys, right?
And this is the most heart-breaking one. Uh,
he writes "This is my long term plan for success.
Step one, zero to five years increased general
social skills and confidence with interacting
with other people. Also, in this time, I hope
to lose my remaining body fat then increase
my muscle by fifty pounds". That's zero to
five years.
"Step two, five to seven years, during this
period I hope to muster the confidence to
approach a woman. I think my body and previous
social skills will aid in this." [laughs]
Makes you feel good, makes you realize, when
I guy comes up to you and you're a woman listening
like a guy a guy comes up to you, you really
hold his entire self-esteem in your hands.
"Step three, seven to ten years. At this point,
I will have no fear of approaching women so
I can start to build my skills up. I will
practice at least one hundred ten minus x
hours a week with x being the number of hours
I'm working." So clearly an engineering student.
"Step four, ten to fifteen years. In this
time period my skills will be getting pretty
good. So within these five years, I hope to
kiss a girl." [laughs] I k now, it gets worse.
"Step five, fifteen to twenty years. By now,
I should be kind of an expert so will be able
to, be able to acquire a girlfriend."
"Step six, thirty to forty years. Die"[laughs]
[audience laughs]
Like he made, if he's off in his plans by
a couple years, he's kind of screwed. [audience
laughs]
And I'll read you the last one which is:
"Dear Neil, I have just come out of the hospital
after trying to kill myself because I read
your book. My father wants to kill you. My
psychiatrist thinks you're an evil cunt that
can't even return email. I want to shoot you
in the face. Where do you live?" Jason.
[audience laughs loudly]
Alright guys, thanks for coming out and thanks
for listening.
[audience applauds]